but turns Makenna theory called the
stoned ape theory glacier to be here
human beings were experimenting with
psilocybin mushroom at SAP salutely
correct
well fungus in general is a freaky
freaky organism yes we are an ape with a
symbiotic relationship to a mushroom and
that has given us self-reflection
language religion and all the spectrum
of effects that flow from these things
wow it's just such a strange strange
concept that's right and DMT is also a
product of endogenous human metabolism
when you look at the DMT experience and
you look at its effect on the human mind
how much of you subscribes to the idea
that we were looking at a some sort of a
chemical gateway it's interesting that
the most intense of the hallucinogens
DMT which you mentioned are the ones
which are most closely related to our
own brain chemistry if this is some sort
of a pathway to a nearby dimension or to
something that's around us all the time
but we just don't have access to with
normal neural chemistry there are many
chemical compounds in nature which are
psychoactive but a much narrower
spectrum of these compounds are truly
what we call psychedelic or mind
manifesting I mean I've never done it
but I know that people who do Kundalini
Yoga have apparently reported trip like
experiences that are very similar to a
real DMT flash so the mind has this
ability to do this on its own the one
thing that is not stressed in Hinduism
as it is exported to the West is the
immense reliance on cannabis a hashish
ganja whatever that DMT experiences that
this is something that your brain has
the ability to travel to toads have been
found which do secrete DMT like
compounds
Wow I feel that potentially psychedelic
drugs could be for psychology what the
telescope became for the science of
astronomy you've had that fantastic joke
I was a talked about that this mom could
practice the city of levitation do you
member this one yes and that the Buddha
came to town and he said for the last 20
years I practiced the city of levitation
and I can now walk on water and the
Buddha said yeah but the fare is only a
nickel that's right
thank you very much for coming in here
man it was a pleasure
the guy was a constant pot user
he was constantly doing psychedelics and
really in soccer he would have a podcast
now right oh it would be amazing yeah
yeah for sure I promote the [ __ ] out